my heaven I can't believe it
a man at last well this is quite an
event I must say this is something I
never expected I was in total shock when
I got the call and the shock is not
quite worn off I have to say I've been
very lucky in my life probably luckier
than I deserved but - at the age of 19
have been chosen by Howard Hawks to work
in a film with a man named Humphrey
Bogart didn't thrill me too much when I
heard it I thought Bogart cause these
dados guys can't what you know I thought
that was not for me he had said maybe
Cary Grant I said well now you're
talking
but it ended up being Bogaerts that was
my great luck because he was not only a
wonderful actor but he was an
extraordinary man and he gave me a life
and he changed my life and he told me
about all the ins and outs and ups and
downs of which there were many and not
so many downs with him and from then on
I must say for as many years as I cannot
believe 60 years but it has been that
long it's amazing isn't it considering
how young I am anyway ah miracles will
never cease the fact is that um I've had
the great good fortune of not only being
shown the way by bogey and and having
two wonderful children who are right
here Steve and Leslie right here with me
and but in also being able to work with
some of the best leading men in this
business and have forged the greatest
friendships with Greg pakkun who I miss
very much and loved very dearly and his
wife gotten away but what are you gonna
do
anyway very food anyway I really was
lucky I really did work with with Kirk
and he said never fear he said to me
backstage never fear Kirk is here
confidence is a great thing isn't it but
Kirk and and Duke Wayne surprisingly had
a marvelous relationship with him for
two movies and Greg and the it's quite
amazing the people that I've worked
worked with I work with Hank Fonda and
unfortunately not really Jimmy Stewart
but some of the all-time all-time greats
and was directed by not only Howard
Hawks who was a marvelous director a
great movie director but John Huston of
course who was the great director and
who showed me the way and tripped me a
few times on roots but he would say he
was a he was a jokester
and because and he loved to laugh and he
had an incredible laugh so you could
hardly blame him
but anyway not to tell you the entire
story of my life I just must say that
I'm I have to thank the Academy and I'm
I'm very grateful that they think I'm
deserving of this honor and as I repeat
I certainly did not expect to receive it
but I do welcome it and thought when I
get home that I'm going to have a
two-legged man in my room is so exciting
I can have this badly
so I would like to thank all of you and
I thank them and what else can I say
it's what I feel and I feel very
emotional and I feel very grateful and
not least of all that I'm still alive I
mean after all some of you are surprised
aren't you nevertheless I am and I'm
here to stay you better get used to the
idea